hey guys it's Friday went down a couple
of people today so we may or may not be
in focus once you got me and then for
you top five episodes let's find out
what's been happening he's rhyming it is
raining oh my god Jess with a huge wake
of video game announcements can you kick
it off tell me what happened episode of
the week alright well Ellen this week we
got word that far cry 5 is coming you'd
be stopped if confirmed it's happening
and I have no more information that's
pretty much all they said they said it's
coming and that it's going to arrive
within this fiscal year which ends on
March 31 of next year
so we know we're getting it kind of
before too long I think we can suspect
we'll hear something at e3 you B have
said that we'll see a more quote very
soon but we don't know the title we
don't know the setting we haven't seen
any art for it except for a slightly
free the 3d sorry far cry 5 logo so I
mean speculate it will if you can but
for now I think we're gonna need to wait
a little longer so this week Bungie
finally revealed a bunch of destiny bits
and pieces we knew we were getting
gameplay oh we did not know how much we
were getting oh we get it so much news
as you've probably seen on site and on
our YouTube channel then won't you use
the highlights so first of all weapons
have changed it's no longer primary
secondary and heavy it is now energy
kinetic and power weapons what that
means I don't know hopefully we'll find
out more soon so supers you've got new
supers the hunter has something called
arks trader which looks like pole dancer
are basically an amalgamation of arc
blade but with the staff now then you've
got the Sentinel which is the new Titan
void super which is basically Captain
America you throw a void shield and you
can absorb damage and then you've got
dawn blade with warlocks which is a
flaming sword if it turns you into being
on fire you can smash down make fire go
everywhere and you can also rain down
fire on your enemies oh boy and I can't
wait to rain down some of that fire upon
at the four new locations you've got IO
heightened might be also here first
European dead zone which coincidentally
was what I call my frizzy and honeymoon
room and finally the unknown place
called meses who knows what that could
be on the multiplayer side crucial is
now four before so no more big big game
modes everything's four before that
means someone whom destiny aren't going
to make the jump over and others are
going to have changes to their play
account to fit in with the new system
which I love I like small
and this is actually kind of something
they haven't said before PC is not being
released at the same time as consoles
it's going to be coming sometime after
and no date has been set
yeah also it's only going to be
available through the blizzard app which
used to be battlenet and it will support
4k and unlock framerate some exciting
news for which your fans today Daniel
hipster hipster which offends well cata
both basically there's going to be a
Netflix series TV series based on the
Witcher books not against the books but
of course the games are based on the
book so you're still getting girls it's
still gonna be the same sorts of themes
I think it's going to be a treat of
course the games aren't directly based
on the stories of the books and it
sounds like the TV series will be but
there's some interesting people on board
are two of the executive producers work
on the expanse which is pretty
critically acclaimed so the author of
the books Andrzej Sapkowski is actually
in the role of very creative advisor on
the TV show which should be really cool
like i george RR martin for campers yeah
which is exciting that and the team
who's putting it together in cooperation
with netflix actually worked on the
cinematics for all three which agains
so there is kind of a connection there
if you're a big fan of the games for the
perhaps i'm read the books hopefully
there'll be an opening shot of growth
Navarre cause I'm not gonna watch it you
know what I don't like what's that the
colors of the joy Kahn controllers okay
well like I like colors a lot but the
red and the blue is not my favorite
however they've just announced agreement
a pink one oh boy how would I get those
Jessica well right now they've only been
announced as available in Japan so the
announcement came through Nintendo of
Japan as part of an extra announcement
that that's going to be a switch
spluttering two bundles
so the splatoon to bundle which is
currently only available in Japan comes
with the game for reset stickers
sticky stamp which plenty of pouring
down sorry sorry uh comes with stickers
comes to the game and clipping the
console
I'm sorry yeah um and there's also been
announcements of brand new accessories
some of them are slow tune things going
to be carrying
if you want to carry your switch around
not like a little carrying case like a
big ass carrying case there's also a
Zelda and arms of things accessories of
course I haven't been announced for
western regions just yet but hopefully
they'll make it over it would be
optimistic that they would I see you
dancing Jess well luckily for you you
can translate that dance there's a new
or boats coming to overseas anniversary
event oh boy it's been about a week
since we last have an overwatch event
and I'm starting to get the shakes cuz
I've got nothing to grind for anymore
then the anniversary event is going to
be kicking off on May 23rd to coincide
with the anniversary of course of our
Watchers launch it also be a game of the
Year Edition coming out in that day
which will get you all the same stuff
from the origins from the origins
edition as well as Tim Lloyd boxes so
there's also new arena Maps coming to
the game and they look to be based on I
convolve a temple of Anubis and Dorado
so that's exciting don't know what that
means whether it's going to be 3v3 1v3
1v1 other combinations of numbers with a
V in the middle and there's also as I
said new emotes and it's all and there's
also a free weekend yeah so if you
haven't played overwatch yet you can
play from the 26th til the 29 yes and
anything you unlock during that free
weekend will carry over to the full game
should you choose to buy it the weekend
to the 26th is a pretty busy one
actually because not only can you play
overwatch for free if you don't have
that one yet you can also click arms oh
you know that's which game with the with
the picture so then else a few new
fighters for a lots of info but dropped
at the Nintendo Direct and yeah one of
those is that they've got two free
weekends actually that weekend and the
one after you can play it for free so if
you want to try that one out then and
that'll be a chance that's it
that's what we got that is everything
we've got do let us know what you
thought of this week's stories remember
you can head to GameSpot for all the
features we put out this week or the
news that's been happening if you missed
anything or if you want to know more
about what we talked about today as I
will be back on Monday so you can see
then
[Music]